some of the most talented performers of
all time reached the end of the road
doing what they loved making movies and
television for devoted viewers across
the globe their sudden passing while on
the job left their cast mates reeling
and fans heartbroken here are a few
stars both young and old whose lives
were cut short while they were hard at
work Redd Foxx on his classic 70s sitcom
Sanford and Son Redd Foxx was famous for
faking a heart attack to get out of a
conversation and audiences loved it Fox
brought the bit out of retirement when
he returned to TV in 1991 with the
sitcom called the royal family but
during rehearsal according to production
spokeswoman Rachel McAllister Fox and
his co-stars were clowning around and
red was sort of breaking people up when
he collapsed they all thought he was
joking at first four hours later at the
hospital
Fox passed away at age 68 of a heart
attack John Eric hexam 26 year old
heartthrob John Eric hexam starred in
cover up a CBS action show in which he
played an elite military operative one
day in October 1984 the producers told
hexam that scheduling issues would delay
filming so he grabbed a prop gun and
quipped can you believe this crap then
he pulled the trigger prop master frank
lo remembered he unloaded all but I
guess one one round what would appear to
be a game of Russian Roulette put it up
to his head the prop gun fired a cotton
wad bullet driving a bone fragment into
his brain which caused severe
hemorrhaging the actor was rushed to the
hospital where he fell into a coma and
passed away six days later John Ritter
well he had a successful film career
with roles in Slingblade and bad Santa
John Ritter will forever rank among our
most beloved and prolific TV actors
she's gonna send you bowling
[Music]
his likability and gift for physical
comedy helped elevate Three's Company
and his return to TV in 2002 as the star
of eight simple rules for dating my
teenage daughter was one of the biggest
stories of the year ABC had renewed the
sitcom for a second season and
production was underway in September
2003 when Ritter suddenly fell ill on
set feeling dizzy and nauseated while
complaining of chest pains ritter
checked into a hospital in Burbank where
doctors treated him for what they
initially thought was a heart attack but
further tests revealed a previously
undiagnosed a or tech dissection which
proved fatal for Ritter
he was just 54 years old Steve Irwin
famously known as the Crocodile Hunter
Steve Irwin was the enthusiastic
Australian nature show host who boldly
ventured into hostile environments to
teach viewers about dangerous and exotic
creatures see why they call him Tiger
Tiger rattlesnakes but in September 2006
as urban and crew were filming a
documentary about the Great Barrier Reef
in Australia
Irwin and cameraman Justin Lyons
encountered an eight-foot-wide stingray
which attacked her when Lions said the
creature launched hundreds of strikes in
a few seconds delivering a fatal dose of
venom and a two inch wide gash over
Aaron's heart he was 44 years old Tommy
Cooper a beloved British entertainer
Tommy Cooper combined corny jokes prop
comedy and magic for an act that was
popular in the UK for decades but
tragedy struck in April 1984 when Cooper
appeared on the live from her majesty's
variety show the show's host Jimmy
Tarbuck
and likely many viewers of the live
broadcast the Cooper was improvising
when he fell to the ground but the
entertainer had suffered a heart attack
the show cut to commercial and Cooper
was rushed to a hospital where he passed
away at age 63 Tyrone Power having
enjoyed a meteoric rise to superstardom
in the 1930s
Tyrone powers breakthrough role in
Lloyds of London came in 1936 when he
was just 22 years old he went on to
establish himself as an
Dreamweaver sattell actor but was most
often cast in swashbuckling adventure
movies such as The Mask of Zorro
in 1958 power landed a title role in
Solomon and Sheba but on November 11
1958 as power shot the 8th take of a
demanding sword fighting scene he
started to shake and said he suddenly
felt chilly and achy
power passed away on route to the
hospital having suffered a fatal heart
attack at age 44
[Music]
you